thank you
[Music]
members take your seats please
the house will come to order
i don't think he understands how many
people there
[Music]
the house will come to order
the chair rick
the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne who's at
the house adjourned from the session of
january 6 2022. are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye
those paul's nay
the eyes have it in the house is
adjourned
the house will attend to a prayer by
house chaplain reverend bob stewart
pastor of saint paul's united methodist
church in manchester
thank you mr speaker
let us be in a spirit of prayer
a loving and gracious god
to us you have entrusted the task of
governing this great state of new
hampshire
make us faithful in our service
keep our hearts centered on those we
represent
and stay centered on the good people of
this state
again we ask for you to give us clarity
and understanding
of each other's viewpoints on the
business before us today
help us oh god to listen closely
to each other
in our voting grant us wisdom and
integrity
guide and help us to be good stewards of
all the resources of time
talent and money that is at our disposal
oh god may we have the strength to stand
tall in the face of conflict
and the courage to speak
with a calm voice
let us do nothing for personal gain or
reputation
but everything to fulfill the mission
you have set before us
as we represent you
and our constituents
you have called us oh god to do the work
on behalf of the state of new hampshire
and to be efficient with that which we
have been tasked with
oh god
ruler of righteousness
lead and guide us today in ways of peace
and justice
inspire us to break down all oppression
and wrong
to gain for everyone their own due
reward
and from everyone their due service
that each may live for all
and all may live for each other
in peace
and harmony
we pray for your guidance and direction
this day oh god
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
manchester rib center mary heath will
lead us in the pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands
one nation
under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
please remain standing for the plane of
our national anthem
[Music]
so
[Applause]
the house will attend to request release
of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives birch cushing ellis
frost mary griffin guthrie harriet
gathright kennedy kimball peter schmidt
spang welch
the day important business
representatives aldridge baxter cody
crawford lundgren mcbride o'hearn
sanborn southworth verville walls the
day illness in the family
representatives elliott and rhodes
these leaves of absence shall be granted
in those otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend to communications
mr speaker
in a letter dated january 24 to 2022
dear governor sununu please accept this
as my formal resignation from the new
hampshire house of representatives the
mishandling of this legislative session
has made it unachievable to safely and
morally perform the duties of this
position
it was an honor and a privilege to work
for my neighbors of hillsborough county
district 38 and i thank all granite
staters for their continuous work
respectfully stephanie highlands
hillsborough county district 38
in a further communication dated
february 15 2022
dear speaker packard i've been proud to
represent the town of merrimack new
hampshire as a member of the house this
past year it has been an honor to serve
our state alongside a dedicated and
hardworking group of legislators it is
great with gratitude and sorrow that i
submit my letter of resignation from the
new hampshire house
recent and unexpected changes in my
family obligations make it such that i
am no longer able to dedicate the time
and attention that this position
deserves
it has been a privilege to represent the
town of merrimack and the state of new
hampshire thank you for your leadership
and understanding sincerely lindsay
tausch
the house will attend to a request for
unanimous consent
representative walner
for memorial remarks
it's awful noisy
this is memorial remarks will members
please be observant
thank you mr speaker
i rise today to remember the honorable
claire clark of boston
claire died on january 15th of this year
it was martin luther king's birthday
she had lived 92 inspiring and
meaningful years
claire who was only four foot 11 inches
was a powerhouse
she may have had the nickname of tiny
but she had a huge personality
claire spent 33 years as a school
counselor at the winnisquam regional
school district
claire always went above and beyond for
her students
often visiting in their homes
talking with their families and being
sure their needs were met
when claire retired
she certainly did not slow down
clara was dedicated to helping children
families and her community
she served 15 years on the merrimack
valley school district
board of board
and her contribution to the schools in
her community was enormous
claire was a woman with immense interest
and she was active in a wide variety of
community services
she served as chair of the boscawen
police commission
she served on the board of the new
hampshire league of hard of hearing
she sang in her church choir and she was
a strong voice for women and children of
color
in the year of 2000
claire's community elected her to the
state legislature
she served here with many of us for 10
years
we remember her as a dedicated and
valued member of the education committee
and one of the first women of color to
serve in our
legislature claire was very proud of her
wonderful family
and her seat in the legislature is now
helped by her daughter representative
caroletta alsaya
her mother was her inspiration and her
mother was so proud of her daughter's
accomplishments
following in your parents footsteps is a
strong tribute to your parents
claire will be remembered here for her
contribution and dedication to bettering
the lives of all new hampshire children
claire will be missed by us
her family her community
and she leaves us with wonderful
memories
and her spirit will always be with us
thank you mr speaker
we all rise for a moment of silence
please
household 10 to senate messages
without objection
mr speaker the senate concurs at the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment in the
passage of which amendment the senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill 95 fn relative to milk
pasteurization
representative pearl moves and we concur
and is recognized to speak
thank you mr speaker i'm on microphone
c3
so this bill came through our committee
and and passed uh unanimously
basically the only thing that the senate
has done is they've added a message to
it to
put on this product is made with raw
milk and is exempt from new hampshire
licensing and inspection raw milk
consuming raw milk may increase your
risk of foodborne illness so i would ask
that you all concur with this bill as
the ena committee
all does thank you
the question is on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it concurrence is accepted
further senate message
mr speaker the senate concurs with the
house and the passage of the following
entitled bill with amendment and the
passage of which amendment the senate
asked the concurrence of the house house
bill 549 relative to the system benefits
charge and the energy efficiency and
sustainable energy board
senate votes moves we concur and is
recognized to speak
thank you mr speaker
on january 7th
this house passed house bill 549 by a
bipartisan unanimous vote
of 343 to nothing
the bill moved to the senate where it
was amended in the enr committee
and then moved to the consent calendar
where it was adopted by the full senate
the amendment makes two changes to the
bill one technical
and one addition
the technical change changes the amount
of money allocated to the easy board to
promote energy efficiency from one
percent of the system benefits charge to
four hundred thousand dollars per year
the addition to the bill
is the critical piece
when the public utilities commission
rejected
the plan for
proceeding with energy efficiency back
on november 12th
it requested the utilities to create a
new plan
and it imposed several mandates on that
the utilities discovered
that those mandates made it virtually
impossible for them to come up with a
new plan
so what the senate amendment does is it
puts into statute
the programming framework and components
of the energy efficiency energy
efficiency plans that were in effect in
puts those
components into statute
so now those energy efficiency programs
can once again proceed
without this amendment
hundreds possibly thousands of jobs
would be lost
and companies might have to cease doing
business
plus the state would lose the benefits
of all the energy efficiency projects
that they are able to accomplish
mr speaker i thank you for allowing me
to explain what this amendment does
and i now ask every member of this house
when called upon
to raise your voice
in a loud reverberating
eye
on this question
the question is on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it
and we concur with the senate message
okay
the house will now
see
the house will now attend to the consent
calendar
mr speaker
from the committee on criminal justice
and public safety house bill 1176
removed by representative abramson
from the committee on criminal justice
and public safety house bill 1340
removed by representative abramson
from the committee on criminal justice
and public safety house bill 1392
removed by representative abramson
from the committee on executive
departments in administration cacr 30
removed by representative abramson
from the committee on executive
departments and administration house
bill 1262 removed by representative
mcguire
from the committee on health human
services and elderly affairs house bill
1642 removed by representative blasic
from the committee on health human
services and elderly affairs house bill
1654 removed by representative stapleton
from the committee on municipal and
county government house bill 1397
removed by representative eamon
from the company on public works and
highways house bill 1040 removed by
representative graham
from the committee on public works and
highways house bill 1656 removed by
representative samsich
are there any other bills to be removed
from the consent calendar
representative osman moves that the
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in today's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it the calendar is adopted
president being declared a conflict of
interest on house bill 1235 fn and did
not participate with the vote on the
consent calendar
under the rules of the house from the
committee on children and family law
house bill 1531 fna is referred to the
committee on finance
commander kennedy on commerce and
consumer affairs house bill 1622 fn is
referred to the committee on finance
from the committee on criminal justice
and public safety house bill 1682 fna is
referred to the committee on finance
from the committee on environment and
agriculture house bill 1547
fn is referred to the committee on
finance
from the committee on executive
departments and administration house
bill 1288 is referred to the committee
on ways and means house bill
1552 fn is referred to the committee on
finance
committee on health and human services
and elderly affairs house bill 3 11 30
fn is referred to the committee on
criminal justice and public safety
and house bills
1526 fn and 1608 fn are referred to the
committee on finance
from the committee on judiciary house
bill 1235 fn has referred the committee
on finance
from the committee on resources
recreation development hb
1339 is referred to the committee on
ways and means committee on state and
federal relations and veterans affairs
house bill
1256 fn is referred to the committee on
executive departments and administration
and from the committee on transportation
house bill 1462 is referred to the
committee on finance
for what member does a member rise
parliamentary in court mr speaker
state your inquiry mr speaker can you
confirm for the membership that your
office has had the opportunity to review
the amendments that are printed in the
calendar for this week and if any of
them have been determined as non-germane
as far as as far as i know none of them
are non-jermaine thank you
we'll now attend to the regular calendar
okay
the committee on children family law to
which was referred house bill 1465 fn
act relative to the appointment of
counsel for the juveniles having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
senator patrick long for the committee
the amendment is 0 6 1 4 h
printing and house record 6 page 65.
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the guys have an amendment is adopted
chair recognizes
representative
uh chair recognizes representative rice
for a motion
thank you mr speaker i moved to lay
house bill 1465 on the table
the question before us is
on house bill 1465 to lay on the table
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and 1465 is laid on the
table
committee on children and family law
which was referred house bill 1647 fn an
act relative to the calculation of child
support having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment joshua
for the committee the amendment is zero
five six six eight printed in house
record six pages eighty four eighty five
the motion before us is on the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
the is happening the committee amendment
is adopted
the question before us is
on the committee ought to pass as
amended
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
under the rules of the house this bill
is referred to finance
majority of the committee on commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred house bill 1237 fn
knacked relative to cigar bars having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative john
petruck for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator richard
abel for the minority of the committee
the amendment is zero four two eight h
printed in house record six page fifty
eight
question before us is on the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
aye those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
the amendment is adopted the question
before us now is the other pass as
amended on
house bill 1237 fn are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
under the rules of the house this is
referred to the committee on ways and
means
majority of the committee on commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred house bill 1469 fn
next prohibiting banks or businesses
from using social credit scores have
been considered the same report the same
with the following amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment of jeffrey greeson
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee ever
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is in
expedient to legislate senator christie
barley for the minority of the committee
the amendment is zero three four two h
printed in house record six page 65-66
the motion before us is on the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes having the committee amendment
is adopted
the chair recognizes
representative
abramson
uh thank you mr speaker uh mr speaker uh
just as oh i can't see you side note
when you're hitting the gavel it's uh
very close to the microphone and it it's
hurting some people's ears
mr speaker
i rise in support of house goal 1469
the motion for ought to pass as amended
we were contacted many times on the
commerce committee by constituents
concerned that their posts on social
media or even
private gun ownership could be used
against them by big banks and financial
institutions it is our responsibility
here in the general court to protect the
rights of our citizens from abuses by
big business big government big banks
big tech or even big lawyers
the bill prohibits banks and other
financial institutions from engaging in
discriminatory practices
for freedom of speech for freedom of
speech to exist private citizens must be
able to post their opinions and
experiences online without fear or
reprisal freedom of speech isn't about
protecting our right to talk about the
weather but whether to talk about the
causes behind the murders of 262 million
people around the world by their own
governments the causes of economic
recession rising crime aids and anything
that might offend those in high
positions
please press the green button
the chair recognizes representative
bartlett
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker i'm here at b1
good afternoon mr speaker and colleagues
i rise to speak in opposition to house
bill 1469 as amended
originally the prime sponsor presented
this bill as necessary against the
quote-unquote woke culture
he repeatedly used this term but when
asked to define it even by our chair he
was unable to provide a definition
in the majority report there's reference
to china and the use of certain criteria
and business transactions
it was stated this bill would prevent
such practices in this country
frankly
arguments in this direction absent any
facts or concerns and possibly based on
internet posts is not a basis for new
hampshire law the new hampshire bankers
association certainly agreed with the
sponsor that banks and businesses
should not discriminate based on
subjective or arbitrary standards
like social media posts and they stated
such in testimony both orally and in
writing
the committee heard testimony from the
attorney general's office
if this office had to review a charge of
discrimination it would be difficult it
would be a difficult investigation or
prosecution and sent a written policy
it's unlikely that a bank or business
would specifically discriminate in
writing
the types of discrimination outlined in
this amendment
furthermore there are
anti-discrimination statutes in place
already making this bill completely
unnecessary
i would argue that we do not need
another law against discrimination
making it more difficult for businesses
and banks to conduct lawful business in
new hampshire
banks are already subject to strict
this bill would add more regulation to
our banking department
but with added difficulties in
determining determining motivation or
fact
please press the no button and mr
speaker i would ask for a division vote
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
greeson to speak for the committee
report
thank you mr speaker i'm over here at
microphone d2
i'm hiding behind the pole according to
your line of view
the majority of the commerce and
consumer affairs committee recognizes
the emergence of a threat of a form of
discrimination that is equally as
repugnant as the practice of redlining
that was commonly practiced by banks and
financial institutions for many decades
and the committee recommends house bill
1469 ought to pass as amended
the emerging threat is a form of
financial discrimination that includes
but certainly is not limited to
banks and other financial institutions
using non-financial criteria as a basis
for whether or not to grant access to
banking and judging a person's or
businesses or an organization's credit
worthiness based on those non-financial
criteria
this is social credit scoring as what is
occurring in china and is apparently
beginning to happen in canada and it has
no place here in the united states
this bill would prohibit the banks
from controlling
your access
to your money
in order to control your behavior to fit
their ideologies
if you think it hasn't happened or isn't
happening it is happening and it's
happening with greater frequency
just this past week td bank decided to
seize the monies that had been donated
to the truckers in canada and turn this
money over to the government the
canadian government
no laws had been broken
the bank just decided they did not agree
with the cause that the money was raised
for refused to turn it over to their to
the proper recipients instead give it
over to the canadian government
just this morning
a fellow american business owner
mike lindell stated that his bank cut
him off
he hadn't broken the law
they just simply disagreed with his
opinions
whether you think he's a kook or whether
you think he's right
that's not the bank's decision to make
those who would naively say this will
never happen need to look at history
because someone said about loading up a
bunch of people onto trains and sending
them off to gas chambers that will never
happen and yet it did
rather than waiting for history of
abuses and then taking action to try to
correct the problem the majority of the
committee believes preventing abuses in
the first place is a better course of
action and recommends house bill 1469
octopass as amended thank you
representative abramson has called for a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take their
seats
roll call
[Music]
so
looks like
house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
weston for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that discrimination is already
fully prohibited in new hampshire
including discrimination in business and
banking transactions
and if i know that this bill intrudes on
the rights of businesses to assess
whether a client or customer is an
appropriate fit for their product
and if i know that the attorney
general's office feels that compliance
with the vague language of this bill
is unenforceable
would i now press the red button to
defeat this motion so another motion can
be brought forward
the chair recognizes representative hunt
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker i'm here at b3
mr speaker is incredible who might
believe
that some financial institutions and
bank in businesses might actually admit
that they are discriminating
because of
gun ownership
will i now assure dictatorship
by
having this kind of discrimination is
not permitted in new hampshire well i
vote yes on the pending motion
question before us this octopass is
amended
it's
on
house bill
1469 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
is
congratulations
so
i
i owe you
it's
yep
[Music]
expedia
representative newton
representative porter could you come see
me again please
never mind
represent porter sorry you're all set
representative vander castille
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend to the state of the boat
180 187 voting yeah 168 voting nay
committee report is adopted
[Applause]
under rules of the house this bill is
referred to
criminal justice committee
majority of the committee on criminal
justice
in public safety to which was referred
house bill 1468 fn an act relative to
the legalization of cannabis having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative casey conley from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator chris true for the minority
of the committee
chair recognizes representative abness
for a motion
thank you mr speaker and i'd like to
make a motion to table
hb 1468
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1468 call please
who requested a roll call
representative
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
okay
mr speaker
i also come to order the chair
recognizes representative true for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this house has
already passed a bill
that would legalize three-quarters of an
ounce
plus allow you to grow your own
and mr speaker if i know that even
though some may say we can't pass 1468
because it will conflict with other
bills
but i also know that if we legalize
cannabis
then cannabis will not conflict with any
state laws at all
because it will be legal
and mr speaker if i believe that the
time has come
to stop bogarting and pussyfooting
around on this issue
but i then press the red button so
another motion can be made
thank you mr speaker
chair recognized representative abbas
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that if
that hp 14 16 14 68 will conflict with
with bills that we've already passed and
bills that we are scheduled to hear
today
and mr speaker i know that it's not a
good policy to have conflicting
legislation that the pass out of this
body should go ahead and push the green
button and support the motion and table
thank you
the question is the i.t the the question
on is on hb 1468 the motion is itl
table
my mistake
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button loading stations
are open for 30 seconds
representative belanger
representative bradley
representative kolansky
representative hatch
representative lockman
representative richards
representative terry
if all members had an opportunity to
vote
also attend the state of the vote
276 voting yay
79 voting nay
the motion to table is adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1540 fn
act relative to recording
custodial interrogations having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation bill ought to pass with
amendment
of david walsh for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate
the amendment is zero six one six h
printed in house record six pages sixty
nine through seventy the question is on
the adoption of the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
amendment is adopted
the motion before us now is the majority
report about the past has amended the
chair recognizes representative true to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker basically
this bill says that any and all
questioning
and interrogations conducted by the
police
must be audio recorded
and or recorded by audio and visual
means
i am sure mr speaker you would agree
that does sound like a great idea
i am also sure mr speaker that with my
clarification
you will agree that house bill 1540
is in violation of article 28a of the
new hampshire constitution
in committee
we heard anecdotal testimony
that most police departments in new
hampshire are already performing these
recordings
the new hampshire association of police
chiefs has stated that many police
departments in new hampshire do not have
the money
nor the equipment to comply with this
bill
in committee we heard anecdotal
testimony that it would not cost that
much
for everyone to be in compliance with
this bill
the new hampshire county attorneys
testified that they do not have the
equipment nor the personnel
to comply with this bill
in closing please allow me to quote from
one of our country's most loved and
respected baritones
of all time
marvin lee a day
so as far as voting for a bill which i
feel is unconstitutional
paraphrasing from that great song by
meatloaf i would do anything for this
house of representatives
but i won't do that
clearly
clearly the new hampshire association of
police chiefs has stated this bill will
downshift cost
clearly the new hampshire county
attorneys have stated this bill will
downshift cost
and clearly the new hampshire
constitution article 28a
states that this legislation shall not
downshift cost to any political
subdivision
please press the red button
to defeat the otpa
so that another motion can be made
mr speaker i request a roll call thank
you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative roy
thank you mr speaker please pardon my
voice i have a little laryngitis
this bill
would require that all custodial
interrogations be recorded either audio
or video not both
one of the other or both if possible
if there is a police department in the
state of new hampshire that cannot
afford a tape recorder we have bigger
problems on our hands than meatloaf
songs
it is very inexpensive
most departments already have it
and furthermore our constitution
protects the individual rights of our
citizens
to have
their day in court and to have a fair
interaction with the police department
color me shocked that the new hampshire
chiefs of police association don't want
to have to record all of their
interactions
unfortunately this is the wave of the
future this is what's happening across
the country and it's the best thing for
our citizens and it's the best thing for
the police
if the police are concerned about
allegations of false confessions there's
no what better way to prove it than that
produce the actual video and audio
recording of
the interrogation
this bill is the best for the citizens
and for law enforcement
i ask you to set aside
your like or dislike for the late
meatloaf and pass this bill thank you
the question before us is the ought to
pass has amended motion on house bill
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
[Music]
me thank you
so
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
testament for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker it's c3
if i know
as you do
that every police station does not have
the capability to record interviews
and
if i know that every police station
doesn't have the capability
or facilities to store catalog and
transmit
these interviews
and if i know
that some police stations would have to
purchase new equipment trained personnel
at facilities at the town or city
expense in violation of article 28a
of the new hampshire constitution
then i would push the red button and i
wish you would too
the chair recognizes representative
conley for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that
recording interrogations provides a
clear and accurate account of what was
said in the interview room and by whom
if i know that most new hampshire police
departments large and small
already record these conversations
and have procedures in place to store
and catalog this evidence
finally mr speaker if i know this bill
protects police as well as criminal
defendants would i press the green bet
button to pass the bill thanks
the question before us is do you want to
pass his amended motion on house bill
it's the roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
this
so
[Music]
representative all chiller
yep
so
representative sotie
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
233 voting yay 122 voting a
committee report is adopted and the
rules of the house
1540 is referred to the committee on
finance
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
1598 fn
an act legalizing the possession and the
use of cannabis having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation of the bill
ought to pass with amendment senate
scott wallace for me for the
committee
mr speaker recognizes representative
agent
thank you mr speaker i'd like to make a
motion state your motion
i'd like to lay 1598 on the table
to imagine it makes a
motion to lay 15
98 on the table
we have a request for a division vote
members will take your seats
[Music]
you again
the eye again
it's a roll call vote members take your
seats
division vote members take your seats
roll
call no it's division vote division vote
division
[Music]
[Applause]
what's
up motion before us
is to lay on the table house bill 1598.
this is the division vote the chair
recognizes the representative adjutant
for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker could i defer my pi to
representative abramson
yes
thank you
mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that that this bill
may still have conflicts with other
pending legislation on the cannabis
issue
and if i also know
that this
uh bill this issue was placed in front
of private citizens on citizens count in
other areas of social media and that the
general public overwhelmingly opposed
what was being proposed here if i know
that the bill is over 20 pages long and
includes four new misdemeanors and
dozens of references to
additional fees fines paperwork and red
tape and if i finally if i know that
this bill has to go to finance committee
because it contains countless fees fines
taxes and millions and millions of
dollars in new spending and possible
bureaucracy would i
press the red sorry the green button to
table this bill
chair recognizes representative
abbas for parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker if i know that hb 1598 is
a bipartisan compromise
and if i know that the policy provisions
provided for in hp 1598 should be
considered on its merits
and lastly mr speaker if i know that hb
1598 will provide property tax relief
for the people in new hampshire should i
go ahead and push the red button and
oppose the motion to table
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is to table house
bill 1598. this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
and then
representative evil
representative loveck
representative sandler
representative mcbride
all minus president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
114 voting yay 238 voting a
tabling amendment fails
[Applause]
a question is now on the majority
committee amendment
0207h printed in house record 6 pages
72-81
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Music]
the committee amendment is adopted bills
on second reading open to further
amendment
representative testament office floor
amendment zero four one seven h
printed in house record six page eighty
one
the chair recognized recognizing
representative testament to speak for
his
floor amendment mr speaker
i'm at c3
uh
my format is fairly simple
there was left out of the bill
any penalty uh if if you gave any
marijuana to any
child
all i did was take the
punishment or the penalty out of the
medical marijuana and place it in
as an addition to this bill thank you
chair recognizes representative abbess
to speak against the floor amendment
thank you mr speaker i rise in
opposition to floor amendment zero four
one seven each
what this what this amendment would do
is create a three hundred thousand
dollar fine
if if someone were to provide cannabis
to a miner although if that is not a i
don't support providing cannabis to
minors
and the bill has written would have a
age restriction of 21 years or older
however
it is felt that that fine would be
excessive considering what the
offense would be
and that that policy provision was not
considered by the committee
and therefore i would
ask everyone to oppose the amendment and
push the red button thank you
question before us is the member
uh does the member yield to a question
remember does not yield
the question is on the
testament floor amendment zero four one
seven h are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
the nays have it and the four amendment
is not adopted
chair recognizes
the question is now on ought to pass as
amended
chair recognizes representative muller
form
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i rise in opposition of hb 1598 because
this bill raises many concerning
questions that have not been addressed
fully
all of us in this room
carry the responsibility to practice
good governance protect public health
spend taxpayers money wisely and conduct
our duties in a transparent way
1598 casts a shadow on each of these
responsibilities
the first intent of this bill is to
legalize marijuana
it does this despite nearly 10 years
worth of data from other states
which documents how legalization in
their states has led to a marked
increase in underage marijuana use
a doubling of marijuana-related traffic
deaths
an immediate rise in child welfare cases
in infants being born with thc present
in their bloodstream and a marked uptick
in hospital documented mental illness
crisis response events
in teens and young adults
despite these tragic consequences we
continue to find ourselves going up the
same tired arguments that legalization
is inevitable and it's time for us to
catch up with the other train wrecks
that's happening in other states
and to add insult to injury
this bill proposes that we use 25
million dollars of
i'm sorry
would you all mind just let me finish
please
that's that's not your job
representative sorry
sir would you mind if i could continue
please thank you
you may continue thank you
and add to add insult to injury this
bill proposes that we use 25 million
dollars of the marijuana profits to fund
drug addiction treatment to help
mitigate a problem we ourselves will
have made far worse
another intent of this bill is to
appropriate 14 million dollars of
taxpayer money for start-up costs so the
new hampshire liquor commission could
manage 10 state-run retail outlets to
sell marijuana to the public
the liquor commission estimates 5
million a year will be needed for
operating costs salaries and benefits
for 70 state employees to sell high
concentrate marijuana
now let's just discuss the transparency
a public hearing was held on the
original bill and then overnight the
bill was amended with three pages of a
banking service proposals and the
amendment was taken up in the executive
session and criminal justice committee
the next day with little or no
discussion
if that's not alarming enough the
amendment contingently appropriates 10
million dollars to execute a banking
scheme in order for new hampshire to
process the anticipated windfall of
profits generated by marijuana sales
this bank scheme is being proposed so
new hampshire can navigate federal laws
that prohibit banks from accepting money
garnered through the sale of a federally
illegal drug
however the u.s treasury department's
financial crimes enforcement network
guidelines still affirm that any bank
used to process cash
from marijuana sales remain subject to
prosecution regardless of state law
another concerning aspect of the
proposed bank scheme is the language
which states that the board of directors
for this bank
shall quote consist solely of the
executive director of the business
finance authority
the attorney general of the state and
the state's treasurer
is this really a good look for our state
to have the state's chief law
enforcement officer and the state's
chief banker sitting on the board of a
private marijuana bank
in one fell swoop
remember we'll suspend for a minute
it's getting awful loud in here the
member has a right
to be heard please keep it down
if you need to have a conversation take
it outside member may continue thank you
in one fell swoop not only does this
bill aim to legalize a drug that we know
will result in more harm to our most
vulnerable populations it also empowers
new hampshire state agencies to
essentially act as a cartel
a drug dealer and a money launderer all
in one
lastly we need to look no further than
the majority report to understand how
the criminal justice committee sees the
purpose of this amended bill
quote this bill as amended allows
consumers to purchase a clean superior
tax-free product at a consumer-friendly
price that is competitive with the black
market
so the state of new hampshire wants to
be protect competitive with the black
market
surely we can be better than this
here are some questions about 1598 that
i would like everyone to consider
why was the public given practically no
ability to comment on the massive
banking scheme proposed in the amendment
will anybody be honest and admit how
unhappy the liquor commission is to be
entrapped in the oversight and
management of the stanks of the state
sanctioned marijuana stores
was an agency consulted before the
extensive banking scheme amended
amendment was added to the bill
did someone from the legislative or
executive branch ask the new hampshire
business authority executive director to
write the amended banking language to
comply with the federal bank secrecy act
on money laundering
and why does the bill indemnify bank
employees and provide for this bank to
have quote a distinct and legal legal
existence separate from the state is
this an admission that the state
government officials are worried about
liability stemming from the sale of high
concentrate thc to the public
in closing here are the final questions
i'd like us to consider
are we practicing good governance by
operating a cartel like marijuana
monopoly
is the state of new hampshire protecting
public health by selling addictive high
concentrate manila marijuana to its
citizens
especially given that it was just
reported that drug overdose deaths in
nashua and manchester recently hit an
all-time high since 2018.
are we spending taxpayers money wisely
by appropriating millions of dollars to
promote and profit from
drug use rather than do what we can to
mitigate our current drug epidemic
are we conducting our legislative duties
transparency transparently by rushing
through an extensive banking amendment
that is intended to navigate around
federal banking laws
and finally
are we really going to sacrifice the
welfare of our citizens over the false
promise of marijuana revenue with no
downside
aren't the lives of our most vulnerable
among us worth more than that
simply put new hampshire has widely
wisely held the line on marijuana
legalization we do not need to become
the first in the nation drug cartel now
mr speaker i respectfully request a roll
call vote when the time comes thank you
remember yield to questions
sure
member yields you may inquire
i have a question
may i ask a question i'm wondering if
the representative is aware of recent
studies out of colorado and other states
where marijuana is legal that it's
actually resulted in a decrease
in the use by minors contrary to what
you have just reported
i'm sorry sir i can't i can't really
fully understand stan what you're saying
colorado has recently reported a
decrease in the use of marijuana by
minors as a result of legalization i'm
wondering if you are aware
of those studies and similar ones coming
out of other states where marijuana is
legal
i'm aware of the fact that colorado is
actually trying to claw back on some of
their some of their legalization
measures because it's been an absolute
disaster i'm also aware that in oklahoma
it's a state actually i do work for
remotely
they've actually they don't have
legalization but they actually allow the
growing
of medical marijuana and use of medical
marijuana and overnight
their farms in rural oklahoma have been
bought up
and they have been transformed into
these cartel businesses they've had a
rush of three types of cartels chinese
mexican in eastern european
every couple months or so they actually
keep changing hands as a money
laundering way to sell their farms at
high profit it's it's a genie out of a
bottle and they can't get it back
thank you remember yield a further
question sure
than oregon you may inquire
thank you very much both sides of the
aisle before you stop the representative
both sides of the aisle are making an
awful lot of noise
i'm asking
let's respect the speakers and the
questions that are being asked please
if you need to have a conversation take
it outside
thank you very much mr speaker thank you
very much for the representative
from hollis i believe for taking the
question is it not true that
hb 1598
although differs in some details is very
similar
to a
bill that was passed
just in the last couple of years and
it's very popular
in massachusetts
sorry sir i can't answer that question
because i'm
i'm new to legislature this is my first
year so i haven't i haven't seen what
was passed to massachusetts last couple
years although i do know from
massachusetts that marijuana sales
actually have just overtaken it's only
taken less than two years of marijuana
sales of actually overtaking liquor
sales in that state
is it remember yield a further question
no i think we're done here remember it
does not yield
thank you mr speaker
colleagues
the last time we met as a body
i stood here
and asked you to consider a different
cannabis bill
it's one that would have legalized
regulated and taxed cannabis sales in
our state
hb 1598 the bill before us today has no
taxes whatsoever
cannabis would be sold to adults 21 plus
under the auspices of the liquor
commission
the state would earn revenue the same
way it does with liquor sales by buying
it wholesale and selling at retail
by avoiding taxes this bill would raise
substantially more money each year
that money would pay for two important
things
substance abuse treatment and education
funding
specifically revenues would be used to
lower the state education property tax
tax relief
education funding
substance abuse treatment these are
concepts
just about everybody in our state can
get behind
as noted this bill would place
regulatory oversight of cannabis with
the state liquor commission that agency
already has ample experience regulating
controlled substances and keeping them
away from children
the agency is also pretty good at doing
business
and just to clarify a point that was
just made the liquor commission took no
position on this bill in committee
the bill contemplates at least initially
only 10 cannabis outlets that would
prevent the oversaturation of cannabis
shops that other states including maine
are now experiencing
so to recap we have a chance to deliver
tax relief
education funding
new money for substance abuse treatment
and legalize a product that majority
upon majority of new hampshire residents
say they want
this is a big win for our state
colleagues i ask that we pass it it's
time to get this done thank you
mr speaker
c3
uh c3 yes does the memory yield uh to a
question
this amendment member does not yield
chair recognizes representative
testerman
i'm going to wave my speech to the
wonderful
speech we had earlier on all the
negative sides of this
chair recognize representative abbas
thank you mr speaker i rise in support
of the committee's recommendation of
ought to pass as amended
hb 1598 as amended is a compromise
by many who favor recreational cannabis
and many who like me
that have traditionally opposed
recreational cannabis
hb 1598 as amended creates a policy like
no other state that works for and serves
the people of new hampshire
rather than create a separate commission
in new bureaucracy recreational cannabis
will be regulated by the liquor
commission
sold in a similar manner as our state
sells liquor
the benefits of this model which new
hampshire already has the infrastructure
in place for
is that new hampshire will be selling
a clean superior tax-free product at a
lower price than any of the surrounding
states
this will encourage out-of-state
consumers to purchase cannabis in new
hampshire
other states made
the mistake of electing high taxes and
costly regulations and this caused
retail prices
to significantly exceed the illegal
market price
new hampshire's tax-free price will
remain competitive with the illegal
market and therefore consumers would
have no incentive
to purchase cannabis illegally
furthermore similar to how other states
are
similar similar to how our state
strategically locates the state liquor
stores retail cannabis stores will fall
in this past this mitigates some of the
potential negative impacts
because there will not be retail stores
in every corner
the revenue from this bill
which is believed to exceed the revenue
from any other recreational cannabis
bill
will be specifically allocated to give
back to the people in new hampshire
as as what to do with that revenue the
first 25 million dollars in net revenue
will be specifically allocated to
drug treatment
substance abuse treatment prevention and
mental health treatment that is related
to substance abuse and after that 90
percent of the net revenue
will be applied to offset the statewide
education property tax
i've heard many
many individuals talk about lowering
property taxes
the time for talking is over it's time
for us together to take action
and to deliver this to deliver
statewide property tax relief for the
people of new hampshire
join me in lowering property taxes all
you have to do
is go ahead and push the green button
and support support the committee's
recommendation of ought to pass as
amended thank you mr speaker
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it isn't
no it is not sufficiently seconded
a division of division has been
requested this will be a division vote
members take your seats
[Music]
hmm
so
members take your seats this is going to
be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative hola
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that 1598 will result in more
harm to the citizens of new hampshire
and it will actually trade off
their that uh that harm for just the
promise of money
would i now press the red button
i recognize representative expedia for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i believe that the prohibition of
cannabis has gone on long enough and
that it is time to create a pathway for
legalization if i believe that this bill
would create
revenue streams to help people with
their property taxes and if i know that
revenue that revenue would also go to
help with mental health services and to
fund our schools then would i now press
the green button
in support of this bill thank you
question before us is on house bill 1598
the motion is ought to pass as amended
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative amanda bolden
representative dolan
representative von plinsky
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
235 voting yeah 119 voting made
committed reporters adopted
under rules of the house the bill is
referred to the committee on finance
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house bill 1516
and act relative to the source of funds
for education freedom accounts have been
considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislators and again glenn cordelli
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
senate margin reporter for the minority
of the committee
chair recognizes representative porter
thank you mr speaker
the microphone doesn't want to work for
me
i go to run right behind you i'll just
hold it i think i'm okay
oh this is nice
thanks man
honored colleagues i rise in support of
hb 1516
relative to the source of funds for
education freedom accounts
new hampshire historical marker number
sits proudly on the front lawn of the
center elementary school in hampton
it reads
first public school in new hampshire
supported by taxation
was opened in hampton on may 31st
1649.
it was presided over by john leggett for
the education of both sexes
the sole qualification for admission
of the pupils was that they be
capable of learning
in new hampshire we have a long and
proud tradition of supporting our public
schools
open to all
and paid for with our taxes
in fact we are constitutionally bound to
provide a free and adequate education to
all children and we do this through our
school districts and our local community
public schools
we are proud too
that our state's public school system
consistently ranks as one of the very
best in the nation
i'm a teacher
i'm a teacher mr mr speaker i wait for
the room to get quiet the noise is
getting to be unbearable in here from
both sides of the aisle
i'm asking again
let the members speak
in quiet
and we will get through this day a lot
quicker
thank you mr speaker
we are proud too that our state's public
school system consistently ranks as one
of the very best in the nation
but because new hampshire still ranks
50th in the nation in state funding for
public schools the cost of operating our
community public schools which are open
to all children
falls squarely on the backs of local
property taxpayers
in fact for most of us the property
taxes collected locally to support our
schools is the largest chunk of that
check
we send twice a year to our town or city
tax collectors
granite staters are also frugal and we
cherish our local control
local voters elect local officials and
charge them with creating a responsible
budget in an open and transparent manner
and with overseeing how our tax dollars
are spent
these locally elected officials are
answerable to the voters to you and me
and if we are not happy we can and often
do
vote them out
that is why i urge you to support hb
1516 which simply states that education
property taxes collected locally shall
not be used as a source of funds for
education freedom accounts
those accounts as you will remember are
overseen and administered by a
scholarship granting organization
who makes all the decisions about how
the money is spent
this organization is not answerable to
us the local voters
new hampshire communities fulfill their
constitutional obligation to provide a
free education to its children through
their local public schools we pay for
them through our local taxes we deserve
a right to say how they are spent
if the state wishes to offer other
educational choices
different from our locally paid for
public schools it certainly can do so
and in fact has done so with the passage
of the budget
passing hb 15 will not impact the
voucher program established in hb2 in
any way
that program is being funded through the
education trust fund and the general
fund with taxes collected by the state
locally collected education property
taxes are not being used to fund that
program now
hb 1516
simply seeks to keep it that way
if you agree with me that local school
taxes should be used to fund local
public schools and that the expenditure
of local funds should be overseen by
locally elected officials answerable to
us the voters
to you and me
then please vote no on the ito motion on
this bill so another motion can be made
thank you mr
speaker do you recognize representative
cordelli
uh thank you mr speaker and mr speaker i
request a roll call vote
and so it starts
the attacks on the education freedom
account program
one of 17 such attacks
we will be discussing
death by a thousand cuts or so they hope
i almost don't know what to say about
this
it is all over the place as you can see
in the minority report
first as the speaker just indicated
education freedom accounts are funded by
the state education trust fund no local
funds are involved
it is a state tax
this bill does and the program does not
use local funds
maybe they've been confused with a bill
that we tabled earlier this year that
did do that
the argument in the minority report
switches to the use of taxpayer funds
to pay for religious schools
i guess the argument is now that
education freedom accounts are okay as
long as funds aren't used to send kids
to religious schools
the u.s supreme court has ruled in
numerous occasions that funds go to the
families who are then free to choose the
program option that meets their child's
needs
most recently espinoza versus montana
and going all the way back to pierce
versus society of sisters in 1924
in which the court stated
a child is not a mere creature of the
state
love that line
all the supreme court decisions have
said that when funds go to a family they
are no longer public funds they are
private funds and it is their choice on
how to use the funds
to exclude religious schools now that
would be unconstitutional as the
supremes have said on many occasions
but what other supreme courts would bill
supporters have us ignore
any suggestions
i could offer one
we just heard about local control
well i believe the best form of local
control is parental control and that's
what this program is all about
so the approach here is to throw things
at the wall and see what sticks
maybe that's the only way to attack a
popular and successful program that
helps children
i started out by saying that i almost
don't know what to say about this bill
but after thinking about it i do know
what to say
i t l green
zimcadelli has requested a roll calls
that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members take their seats
roco
[Music]
house will come to order the chair
recognizes representative cornell for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i believe that
the intent of this bill is to protect
local taxpayers dollars and to keep them
local and if i know that there were only
four people online who registered to
oppose this bill
and if i know that my constituents do
not want their local school tax money
paying for educational freedom accounts
out of the district but instead going to
their local public schools
if you agree with me that local tax
dollars should remain in local schools
please join me and press the red button
so another notion can be made thank you
chair recognizes representative ladd for
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much mr speaker if i know this bill is
another attempt by the education
establishment to undermine education
choice and the education freedom account
program
and if i know that using efa funds for
quality learning at religious schools
has been found constitutional by the
highest court in the land the u.s
supreme court
and if i further know the efa program
initially initiated less than one year
ago
has received overwhelming support from
parents
seeking the best education fit for more
than one thousand eight hundred children
would i then press the green button on
behalf of new hampshire families thank
you
the question is on
the
expedient to legislate report on house
bill 1516
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative crawford
here
representative folsom
uh
okay
mr speaker
baltimore's president had an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to stay to the vote
181 voting yay 174 voting nay
committee reporters
adopted the last one
recommendation
after speaking
the chairman of finance and the chairman
of ways and means speaking
house bill 1598 is being referred to the
committee on ways and means not finance
[Music]
committee on education to which was
referred house bill 1624 fna
an act relative to students with
disabilities participating in
co-curricular activities and making an
appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass is in a
michael moffatt for the committee
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes haven't the committee report is
adopted and the rules of the house it is
referred to the committee on finance
committee on education to which was
referred house bill 1627 fna an act
establishing an education freedom
account program administrator in the
department of education making an
appropriation therefore having
considered the same report the same the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass is in a bomb for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it the
committee report is adopted rules of the
house bill is referred to the committee
on finance
majority committee on education to which
was referred
house bill 1657 fna an act establishing
a new hampshire farm to school
reimbursement program having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution that is in
expedient to legislate
ralph baum for the representative ralph
bone for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill be
re-referred for interim study senator
linda tanner from the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes representative
tanner
thank you mr speaker
hb
is a bill to encourage and promote a new
hampshire farm to school program
it is not a required program for our
schools
it is a start-up grant program
to encourage and assist schools in early
child care sites
to initiate and implement a
collaboration with local farms
to bring healthy
locally grown food to our children
farm to school programs exist in every
state and are part of the farm to school
network
there are about 26
new hampshire schools who are currently
buying directly from a farm or
purchasing local foods through a
distributor and have youth gardens
the program works in three areas
first
it assists in the setup of a procedure
to have local foods like apples and
carrots purchased and served to students
as snacks
or part of their meals
secondly it provides students with
hands-on experiential learning
activities related to agriculture food
and nutrition
through school gardens students get
hands-on experiential learning and
growing food and an appreciation for
farming
at the same time this program provides
an opportunity for local farmers a lot
of them family farms
to market their products to engage with
schools to have higher visibility in the
area and to share their love of farming
and agriculture
in our committee
the new hampshire commissioner of
agriculture stated that he thought the
program has great potential for our
children
and our local farms but still needs some
work
through a study committee in
collaboration with the department of
education
the northeast farm to school
collaborative perhaps the unh extension
service and other interested groups the
specifics of funding and implica
implementation can be worked out
new hampshire farm to school is a winner
it's a win-win
win
it's a win for the kids who will be
getting nutritious foods rather than the
packaged foods found in many school
lunches and snacks
they'll have fun gardening and learning
about where their food comes from
it's a win for local
family farmers to have increased
visibility in a new local market
and the final win is for communities by
providing opportunities to build family
and community engagement through
supporting our local family farms and
strengthening the local economy
i urge you to vote no on this itml
motion so a motion of interim study can
be offered thank you mr speaker
chair recognize represent obama
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee
recommendation of itl
this is also a 28a issue
there will be an additional cost of
schools for setting up the program
and also where does the state come up
with the more than 600 000
for the doe
school districts can now work
with their local farms
for the few months that food may be
available
we don't farm year round unless from
milk and eggs where you're going to get
it the commissioner of agriculture also
testified to that effect there's only a
few months of the year
that farms
produce is available schools can already
do this if they want we don't need to
spend additional money thank you
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
mr speaker i'd like to ask for a roll
call vote on this
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
[Music]
okay
so
house will come to water this will be a
roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative hall
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that when school districts buy
food from local farmers new hampshire
school children eat fresher healthier
food
and if i know that supporting local
farmers
strengthens communities and local
economies
and if i know that when schools build
relationships with local farms
educational opportunities emerge
would i now vote no on the itl motion
and push the red button so the motion
for interim study can be brought forward
for this important bill
chair recognizes representative ladd for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much mr speaker
if i know school districts may currently
purchase locally grown farm products for
school meals without the need for
legislation
and if i also know the department of
education estimates that program
start-up responsibilities will result in
additional state appropriations as well
as unfortunate unfunded up costs to
local school districts and lastly if i
understand this bill has good intent or
potential however it is simply not ready
and needs much more work beyond time
available for study this year would i
then press the green button
question is on the motion of itl on
house bill 1657 this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're approached you'll press
the red button voting stations were open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative lorenzo
representative thiberge
representative sumsitch
representative schultz
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
[Music]
house will attend to the state of the
vote
186 voting a
164 vote in a committee report is
adopted
threesome
thank you
the majority of the committee on
education which was referred to house
bill 1660 fn and act relative to school
lunches and establishing the meals for
students fund having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution
resolve that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative deborah hopson
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative arthur ellison for
the minority of the committee
chair rep
recognizes the member from conway
representative woodcock to speak against
the committee report thank you mr
speaker good morning
actually good afternoon
i know that there hasn't been a large
number of successes during coven
yes new hampshire like all states
received a large sums of money to help
with covert relief
some workers received extra pay
schools got a chunk of help to offset
the costs of hvac system to provide
additional cleaning supplies
the lob saw new purifiers the list goes
on
most of these monies were used to reduce
the costs of cities town schools and our
own legislature
money we probably would have not
preferred to have if we could bypass the
two years of
stress illness and inconvenience but
alas
there was one positive result that has
been the schools of the new hampshire
like most states began to offer all
children breakfast and lunch daily
we've heard stories about teachers staff
parents and volunteers delivering meals
via the school bus
every day stop by stop during the first
year of the pandemic when most children
were home
this process was supplemented by
multiple programs on meals for weekends
we'd like to start like programs like 68
hours of hunger thinking just one
most communities have something to help
reduce the food needs for children
throughout the weekends
money to communities are provided to run
food feeding programs for children out
of schools and recreational sites
throughout the summer months for the
same reason
food is scarce or non-existent
on a regular basis for many of our new
hampshire children
we recognize homelessness
as is prevalent in almost every city in
town new hampshire
and it's in the newspapers for one
reason or another almost every day
but food insecurity
not knowing when or where your next meal
will come from
is a real thing for our students
it's a double or triple whammy
research is chock full of data that
connects good nutrition
and student success
kids need nutritional food to fuel their
brains in their bodies
i would guess that many of us in this
room usually
just grab a cup of coffee in a suite and
we're on our way
a good choice
probably not
but for a host of reasons
we had the option
there was food in the house
but we had the money to stop at the
corner store or gas station or dunkin or
pay four bucks at starbucks for a cup of
java by the way that four bucks would
pay for 10 students to have a
nutritional breakfast and lunch for one
day
at school under hb 1660.
the point is
that way too many kids do not have the
basic food at home or their parents or
single parent
do not have enough money to buy
breakfast for the kids
i bet that
like me
many of your parents made you have
breakfast every single day before going
out to school
my dad would lecture me on a regular
basis
how breakfast is the most important meal
of the day
for those of you that took cycle 101
many moons ago
just think back on maslow's hierarchy
needs
or if you can't recall what it was i
recommend that maybe you google it after
the lieutenant is done giving his pi
maslow was right then and he's right now
i began a few minutes ago talking about
a plus a positive resolution
that hidden under the multiple layers of
gloom and aggravation is one
children had food daily
all yes all children had access to food
not free food by any means
our taxes paid for it but children had
food at least five days a week that they
and their parents could count on
i listened at the exec session and read
in the blue calendar a quote that was
made
it's the parents responsibility
remind you another quote
that said just let them eat cake
the reality is there is no food on the
table or in this case in their stomachs
and we're wasting millions of new
hampshire tax dollars trying to educate
kids when they're hungry and unfed on a
regular basis
ladies and gentlemen that's hb 16-16
nutshell breakfast and lunch daily to
students that meet the federal
low-income guidelines
this isn't like the current covert
response where every child regardless of
family income gets a female at school
although i wish it was
nope
hb 1660
restricts itself to those families that
meet the federal low income guidelines
those that have empty pantries and empty
stomachs
the doe estimates
40 cents a day per student as the actual
new hampshire cost after the federal
school meal reimbursement
no new hampshire student should have to
start today hungry because of their
family's poverty
please vote no
on the itls or an otp motion can be made
40 cents a day that seat
to feed the most hungry and needy
students in new hampshire
thank you mr speaker i request the
division
vote the chair recognizes the member
from east kingston representative hobson
speak in support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
this bill requires schools to make free
or reduced cost breakfast and lunch
available to children
who meet federal eligibility guidelines
and provides reimbursement to schools
in the education hearings we learned
that of 406
schools taking advantage of the school
lunch program
only 30 were not already providing
breakfast
the cost of starting up the program
personnel to oversee and run the program
are not funded in fiscal years 23 the
cost would be 642
000.
in fiscal year 24 it would be 640
and in
fiscal year 25 655
with only 30 schools in new hampshire
not participating participating in the
program it would seem to be a matter of
choice over costs
for this reason i request you support
the itl motion and vote green
the question before the house is the
majority committee report of in
expediency legislate on house bill 1660
representative woodcock has requested a
division vote this will be a division
vote members please take your seats
division
so
uh
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
ellison for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that research shows that
hungry children have a lack of focus on
learning
and ultimately lower test scores
and if i know that new hampshire is the
fifth richest state per capita in the
country
but yet some of our families still do
not have sufficient income to provide
enough food for their children
nor do all new hampshire school
districts offer a free and reduced price
breakfast and lunch program
and mr speaker if i believe that the
headline from today's session
should be republicans and democrats
unite to feed hungry kids
would i now push the red button to
defeat this motion so that an abortion
can be brought forward thank you mr
speaker
the chair recognizes representative
nelson for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that there are approximately
30 schools that do out of 460 that do
not offer a free breakfast or lunch
program and or
if i know that it would be best to
resolve this issue on the local level
with the different towns making their
decision
would i then press the green button in
support of the itl motion
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green one a
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red to be button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
uh
[Music]
representative salloway
representative macbeth
representative loan
representative klein knight
representative le branch
representative ham
representative heath
representative
barry representative heir
yeah we can't bring the whole head with
it
he can do that in under 10 seconds with
his eyes closed
so
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
177 having voted in the affirmative 174
on the negative the committee reports
adopted
mr speaker
what reason does remember us i rise to
make a motion to reconsider
house bill 1660 and recommend we vote no
representatives erosion moves
reconsideration of house bill 1661
and it'll be a division vote members
please take your seats
division
anybody over there yeah
i should just call him anyways
okay
oh okay
all right the house will come to order
the question is whether to reconsider
the vote on house bill 1660
representative greene is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry no
sorry woodcock
thank you
representative green will be right up no
problem okay
thank you so much mr
students of new
hampshire students in new hampshire
if
i if i knew that parliamentary and if
you and okay we'll try again if i know
the students of new hampshire who attend
those 30 schools that were mentioned
aren't registered with doe
and if i know that this applies to all
the other schools in new hampshire
and if i know also that this is kind of
a
tough thing a mean-spirited attempt
to
stop youngsters who are hungry and need
food where i vote yes
so one of the things we don't do is get
personal or characterize motives in the
new hampshire house representative
woodcock
representative labs recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much mr speaker if parents and i know
that all students deserve proper
nutrition
but if i also know
this is a local control
issue
associated with local school districts
would i then press the red button thank
you
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green one a
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red to b button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
representative contoir
represent ham
representative salloway
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
176 having voted in the affirmative 179
on the negative the motion fails
committee amendment
mr speaker
for what reason does this memorize a
point of personal privilege
mr speaker i would like to appreciate
oh i i apologize go ahead thank you
together i'd like to apologize to the
group and the representatives as you as
well i meant no ill intent by my
comments uh previously a little
emotional thank you
thank you
[Applause]
all right so we got a committee
amendment
got it
the question before the house is
oh i do don't i
the committee on education which was
referred house bill is 1661 fn local an
act relative to regional career
technical education agreements having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
representative rick ladd for the
committee the committee amendment is
zero three five six h printed in house
record six on page eighty seven
the question is on the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
and the amendment is adopted
now the question is the majority
committee report about to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
oh dear
further
for the rules of the house the uh
hb 1661 is referred to the committee on
finance
the majority of the committee on
education which was referred to house
bill 1684 fn a local an act limiting
education freedom account funding to
budgeted amounts having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
glenn cordelli for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment in the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative david
luno for the minority of the committee
the question is on the majority
committee report have been expedient to
legislate the member from and
representative luna was recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you very much mr speaker
house bill 1684 requires the education
freedom account program to be held to
budgeted amounts isn't that what we do
for state-run programs
isn't this what we do for programs that
sometimes are hard to budget for
isn't this what we do for dcyf and the
budget for caseworkers
isn't this what we do to support people
with developmental disabilities
but the education freedom account
program isn't held to its budget
last june the department of education
recommended a budget
of twenty nine thousand dollars
and by november costs had exceeded eight
million dollars
so how did this happen
the department used participation rates
based on a similar program in arizona
the department estimated that 75 percent
of students who participate
would directly be coming from exiting
their public schools
according to the department the savings
advantage for new hampshire taxpayers is
when a student leaves their public
school to enter the voucher program
presumably presumably saving the local
property taxpayer from having to pay the
per pupil cost to educate this student
and not costing the state any more than
it was already paying to the student
school district
but that's not what happened
instead most of the students who signed
up were already attending private
schools or being homeschooled these
students had already made the choice to
leave their public school and weren't
costing the state a dime
but now we're all paying for it
not the budgeted amount of 129 thousand
dollars but more than eight million
dollars
and that number's going up
not because the program is wildly
successful
not because it's quote freeing students
from quote oppressive public schools
but the numbers going up because it's a
blank check to make taxpayers pay for
someone else's private school tuition
and homeschool costs
free money free money free money
the director of the legislative budget
assistant office projects the state
exposure to be more than 70 million
dollars a year
house bill 1684 would stop this runaway
train
the department of education would be
held to present and defend a budget
that goes to the stated objectives
for instance to provide students from
low-income backgrounds access to
education opportunities outside of their
public schools
and they could be questioned by
lawmakers to make sure taxpayer money is
actually being used to open doors for
students and families
i hope the house will look favorably on
truth and budgeting budget integrity and
the obligation to spend taxpayer money
wisely
this bill doesn't kill the program it
lets the efa program both succeed and be
fiscally responsible at the same time
please vote no on the motion of itl so
that another motion can be made to
protect taxpayers and accommodate
students already in the program thank
you does the member yield for a question
no i don't
the member from shuffling borough
representative cordelia is recognized
speak in support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker and i request a
roll call vote
here it is attack number two
this bill would establish an arbitrary
budget for the education freedom account
program
this bill would decimate the program
it would throw
1800 kids
out of the program who are currently
being helped
and possibly force parents to pay back
any efa funds they have used to educate
their children this year can you imagine
that how can we possibly let that happen
the goal of this program is evidently
aimed at the number of children that can
take advantage of the program
people are clearly scared of the success
of this program as measured by the
number of students electing for efas
the minority report
says that the department of education
and i quote should be held accountable
because of their estimates and
underestimating the number of students
taking efas
but this bill has nothing to do with the
department the bill would punish
families and children who are just
trying to find the best education to
meet their needs
what would bill supporters tell parents
and kids who are kicked out of the
program
parents are paying more attention to
their children's education than ever
before
and they are watching what we do and how
we vote here today
you see we've always heard the claim
that it's about the kids
well the truth is for many it's about
the money
and parents know that
parents can see what's going on in many
schools and they're not happy
and people wonder why this program is
successful
we have a choice today
throw kids out of the education freedom
account
incur the wrath of their voting parents
or
we can continue to provide opportunities
for children to get the education that
they need
the education that will help them become
successful adults
the education they need to help keep new
hampshire the free state in the nation
and a thriving state into the future
we have a choice today
what say you
i say itl
the question is on the majority
committee report of in expediential
representative cordelia has requested a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members please take
receipts
roco
foreign
the house will come to order
the questions on the majority committee
report have been expedient to legislate
on house bill 1684 this is a roll call
vote
representative mullins recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you so much mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that the department of
education originally estimated the cost
of the education freedom voucher program
at 129 000
but it actually cost 8.1 million this
year
a 6 000 percent miscalculation
and if i know that the legislative
budget assistant has calculated the
projected risk of this program to the
taxpayer at 70 million dollars a year
given the number of private school and
home school
currently enrolled students that are
likely to enroll in the program
and if i believe that few hard-working
new hampshire families would even
consider betting the farm
against a
poorly estimated quickly adopted
and
scheme that hardly anyone truly
understands and that every family
knows how important it is to stick to
the family budget
would i now press the red button to vote
against the committee report so that
another motion can be made
representative loud is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much mr speaker if i know
this bill is yet another attempt to
decimate
decimate the education freedom account
program
and if i also know the average cost to
sustain a child in the new hampshire
public school system approximates
twenty thousand dollars per student
while the cost for an efa account per
student is only one quarter the state
per pupil cost
and if i know this program is
wildly success successful
has enrolled 1800 students
and engages students in quality learning
would i then press the green button
to support this successful program
and physically responsible program thank
you
the house will be in order
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green one a
button if you're opposed you'll press
the green be button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
representative perezni
representative cushman
representative o'brien
representative seaworth
representative bill boyd
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
182 having voted in the affirmative 171
on the negative the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
election laws
on the previous bill representative
seaworth declared a conflict and did not
participate
the majority of the committee on
election law to which was referred
house bill 1423 fna an act relative to
campaign contributions and expenditures
and making an appropriation therefore
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative fenton grown
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative russell muirhead for
the minority of the committee
member from hanover representative
moorhead is recognized to speak against
the committee report
thank you mr speaker
this bill
house bill 1423
establishes
a framework
for voter owned elections
governor and executive council in new
hampshire
the bill
would disempower go a long way toward
disempowering the donor class
that dominates politics on the left and
right
by making it possible
for every voter
to become a donor
every voter would receive
four
25 dollar certificates that they could
direct
to any qualified candidate
candidates would qualify to receive
these certificates
by collecting lots of small donations
from in-state voters
a candidate for the governorship would
have to collect twenty five hundred
five dollar donations ninety percent of
which would need to come from
new hampshire
residents
in order to qualify
for these voter dollars
this system
would give candidates a very strong
incentive to focus
all of their attention
on new hampshire voters
and it would give candidates who do pay
attention to new hampshire voters
a real chance
against those candidates who would
rather court
out of state big money
this bill
creates a framework
for voluntary voter owned elections
it would allocate one dollar
toward this
fund
in order to create a line in the budget
for it future legislation would be
necessary
to fully fund
this system
this bill is about endorsing the concept
and it would cost one dollar
to the state of new hampshire to do so
legislation like this a system like this
has been working
in maine
since 1996
and that system has the support
of people on the left and the right
democrats and republicans admire it and
defend it in our neighboring state
some say that this system would be too
expensive
but it's a lot less expensive
than the perception of corruption
that causes citizens in large numbers
especially young citizens
to lose their faith in constitutional
democracy
thank you
the house will be in order
member from rochester representative
groan is recognized speak in support of
the committee report
thank you mr speaker
hb 1423 provides a mechanism for
taxpayer funding of one million dollars
for candidates for governor and sixty
thousand dollars for candidates for
executive council
i might say here that though the bill
currently provides a one dollar
initial budget
if one candidate took the million
dollars that will be offered under this
bill i would suggest that it would go
considerably further over budget than we
discussed in a previous bill here
the majority of the election law
committee believes that candidates who
wish to represent citizens of new
hampshire in their government should not
have their campaign funded by the
government they wish to serve in that's
an inherent conflict of interest
campaign financing has long been a
controversial issue
at both state and federal level
legislatures and the courts have spoken
on this issue over time and have
produced transparency for and limits to
political contributions
transparency is provided by detailed
reporting that is required of all
political candidates and pacs
we can from our existing laws determine
where political money comes from and to
whom it is contributed our laws also
provide limits to the amount of each
contribution that can be received by a
candidate for office in new hampshire
the majority of this committee believes
this bill is unnecessary and would not
result in cleaner election funding i
might add here that
there is a
an assumption in this
legislation
that government money
is cleaner
than private money an assumption i don't
believe i agree with
i urge you to support the itl motion
for this bill does the member yield for
a question
yes i do
representative baltissara you may
inquire thank you mr speaker uh thank
you representative take my question the
last speaker i get a little bit confused
i keep hearing over my friends over
there that we're a democracy
constitutional democracy are we a
republic was it discussed in your
committee that we are a constitutional
republican
that was not discussed in our committee
but we certainly are a constitutional
republic
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 1423 are you
ready for the question
division votes been requested this will
be a division vote members please take
your seats
division
so
me
all right
the house will come to order
the questions on the majority committee
report have in expedience a legislate on
house bill 1423
representative porter is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
mr speaker if i know recent polls of new
hampshire voters
show 80 percent
believe big money and special interest
have more influence on new hampshire
politics than voters do
and that two-thirds support some public
funding of campaigns so that their
voices can be heard more loudly
and if i know this bill is the result of
a 2018 public financing working group
made up of six legislators two senators
four representatives i don't know how
they got the two senators but they did
half democrats and half republicans
including present and past chairs of the
election law committees
after more than 20 years of study
and if i know that participation in the
public funding program is entirely
voluntary and allows candidates who are
funded by small donors to have a real
chance
then would i press the red button to
vote down the itl motion and let the
voters have this say thank you
representative grohn's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that this
bill will not limit or reduce dark money
being spent on election on the election
process
and if i know that this bill will not
limit or reduce money a candidate for
governor or executive council can raise
for their campaigns
and if i know that this bill will
require new hampshire taxpayers to fund
governor campaigns for a million dollars
and executive council races for sixty
thousand dollars
in
the situations described in this bill
then would i press the green button to
support the itl motion on this bill
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green one a
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red to be button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative fargo
represent mckinney
representative mirner
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
191 having voted in the affirmative 165
in the negative the committee report is
adopted
committee on election law to which was
referred house bill 1482 fn
an act relative to rank choice voting
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator peter teroshan for the
committee
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Music]
[Applause]
i heard you the first time
representative
this will be a division vote members
will take their seats
no
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
foreign
please
represent conley
representative khan
representative harvey
representative johnson
representative cofoult
representative mick williams
representative sweeney
representative welkowitz
president had an opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
205 voting yeah 149 voting 80 committee
report is adopted
committee on election law which
to which was referred house bill 1484 fn
an act requiring a forensic audit for
the 2020 election results having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient allegedly
representative catherine prudhomme
o'brien for the committee
mr speaker
what purpose what purpose does a member
rise mr speaker i'd like to make a
motion to table 1484.
that is an appropriate motion the motion
on house bill 1484 is to lay on the
table
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
yes it is officially seconded this will
be a roll call vote
mr speaker
mr speaker may make a parliamentary
inquiry
uh yes mr speaker right now i'll call
you
um
this will be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes
representative
barry for a parliamentary inquiry uh yes
mr chairman if i know that 1484 was
unanimously brought out of committee and
that this body has other things to go
focus on would i now vote would i now
press the green button to support the
motion to lay on the table
the question is to the motion to lay on
the table on house bill 1484. this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative bailey representative
baldassaro representative belanger
representative binford representative
bixby representative boards
representative cannon
representative conley representative
edwards representative ellison
representative barbara griffin
representative gagne
representative
judy
representative clee
representative maggiore
representative mcaleer
representative mann
representative mickey
representative miler excuse me melvin
representative jody nelson
representative o'hara representative
osborne
representative panalakis representative
piamonte
representative shapiro
representative tripp representative vale
representative varney
representative
speaker
wells
representative woods
representative harvey bullier
all right sir
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
273 voting a 76 vote in may the motion
to table
passes
mr speaker chair recognizes
representative pearson to make a motion
thank you sir i would like to have
special ordered house bill 1662 please
that is a
to win
now
okay
would you like to explain why uh the
person who worked very very hard
on this both in health human services
oversight and in the committee
is presently here and we're not sure how
much longer he will be available so we
would like him to speak to the great
work that he did
the motion before us is to special order
house bill 1662
to the next bill on the calendar
all those in favor say aye those opposed
nay
the eyes have it
so um there's no debate but edwards
wants to speak okay so just read through
the thing okay all right
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was referred house bill 1662 fn
it's getting awful noisy again
members
will be quiet
an act relative to privacy obligations
of the department of health and human
services having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
senator jeffrey soloway for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study president of leah
cushman for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is zero five seven seven h
printed in house record six pages eighty
seven and eighty eight
motion before us is the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
no suppose nay
the eyes have it and the committee
amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes representative
edwards
thank you mr speaker and uh thank you
fellow uh house colleagues for this
special order
um
this
bill was was presented in a stream of
events
that started in 2018 with the passage of
our right to privacy into the new
hampshire constitution that was 2018.
then in 2021
the hhs oversight committee conducted uh
our own privacy audit of the department
of health and human services
that triggered the bill that we're
voting on today the the bill that we're
voting on today
estab is is the next logical step in the
process
of putting infrastructure key
infrastructure in place
to match
a corporate governance structure
it also requires risk mitigation
planning
in the name of a privacy impact
assessment
establishes a couple of new positions
with specific skills to investigating
privacy issues and i.t security issues
to come up with mitigation
recommendations
so
all together i
think that this bill is the next logical
step in the progression of protecting
our citizens privacy
and those
that
came to me before the hearing and said
they had to oppose it i think were
principled individuals i didn't hear
myself disagreeing with our principles i
wasn't saying no i was saying not yet
because there's still time
in either this session to hear bills on
the topics of opt-in opt-out for future
years if if we don't find that the
department is complying with these uh
privacy requirements
so
so with that i would ask
for an affirmative vote on this i don't
believe there's anyone speaking in
opposition
and i'd be perfectly happy with the
vote
voice vote
mr speaker
the question before us is the majority
report of octopass has amended on house
bill 1662.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred house bill
1496 fn
an act requiring political subdivisions
to make voter checklists available
and spreadsheet form to any resident
having considered the same report the
same
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator ross barry
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative paul bergeron for the
minority of the committee committee
amendment is zero six three four h
printed in house record six pages 66
through 67.
uh are you ready for the question on the
adoption of the amendment all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes happen the committee amendment
is adopted
the motion before the question before us
now is the majority report brought to
pass as amendment the chair recognizes
representative bergeron
thank you mr speaker
the language in house bill 1496 is
amended
will not accomplish what the bill's
title suggests it will
that is to make voter checklists
available in spreadsheet form to any
resident who requests it
current law says that the supervisors of
the checklist or city or town clerk
may provide the checklist in any form
the format chosen is at the discretion
of the supervisors of the checklist or
the clerk
the amended bill states that the
supervisors of the checklist or clerk
may provide the checklist as a paper or
electronic copy
again the format chosen is still at the
discretion of the supervisors of the
checklist or the clerk
there is no requirement that the
checklist be provided in spreadsheet
form
the amendment states that electronic
lists shall be the version updated
within the last 31 days
but the supervisors of the checklist
don't meet every month in fact most of
them just meet prior to elections to
approve all the applications that have
been submitted
from residents who want to be added to
the checklist
so that provision has little practical
relevance
finally during the public hearing on the
bill
concerns were raised that the
distribution of checklists in electronic
form
to any resident upon request
would intrude upon our citizens right to
privacy
anyone can go to the city or town
clerk's not office now to see the
checklist at any time during regular
business hours
but once a spreadsheet containing the
names and addresses of voters is
released to anyone
that information can be sorted
manipulated and migrated to other
databases
so that the mailing addresses can be
used for commercial or other purposes
current law says the checklist can't be
used for commercial purposes
but how would that be controlled if this
bill passes
the bill as amended is flawed and won't
accomplish what it was intended to
accomplish
we should not have passed a bill with an
expectation that the senate will fix our
mistakes
the bill is poorly written
and should be found in expedient to
legislate
chair recognizes representative barry
thank you mr speaker the title of hb
1496 requiring political subdivisions to
make voter checklists available in
spreadsheet form to any residents
thankfully we have this thing called
legislative intent
mr speaker the inf the word here is
publicly available checklist that's
correct the list is already publicly
available as the member of the minority
party mentioned anyone can walk into any
town clerk's office and see the publicly
available checklist what we are doing
here mr speaker is we are balancing
transparent elections
with
the ability for the average person to
access information and balancing privacy
so what we did mr speaker was we amended
it to where if you are requesting the
publicly available checklist you must be
a registered voter of that town
mr speaker this bill as amended will
increase election transparency it
balances the right to privacy
and it will help make election people's
faith in the elections increase with
that i ask that you pass 1496 as amended
the motion before us is the majority
report of what past has amended on house
bill 1496.
a division has been requested by
a division has been requested members
will take their seats this will be a
division vote
[Music]
some of these were going to have i mean
kind of salespersons
okay
the motion before us is out to pass as
amended on house bill 1496.
the chair recognizes representative
bergeron for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that there is no requirement
in current law or in this bill that the
supervisors of the checklist must
provide a checklist in the format that
the requester is asking for
and if i know that the supervisors of
the checklist do not meet every month so
the requirement that the list being
provided is one updated within the last
31 days has no
practical relevance
and if i know that releasing the names
and addresses of registered voters to
anyone requesting them in a format that
can be used for commercial purposes is
an intrusion on our citizen's right to
privacy
but i then press the red no button in
opposition to the motion about to pass
as amended so that a subsequent
amendment may be made
chair recognizes
representative sweeney for parliamentary
inquiry
mr speaker if i know that the
information regarding this bill is
already publicly available
uh and mr speaker if i further know that
this bill simply updates existing
statute
in an effort to save taxpayers and those
requesting the information
funds would i now press the green button
thank
you the question is on the majority
report of how to pass as amended on
house bill 1496 this is the division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative kelly pitts
representative vincent
where
else all members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attained to the state of the vote
183 voting a
169 voting a committee report is adopted
uh under house rules the
bill 1496 fn has referred the committee
on finance
committee on environment agriculture to
which was referred house bill 1226 fn
that prohibiting the declaring of cats
have been considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to
legislative representative howard pearl
for their committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
committee report is adopted
majority committee on environment and
agriculture which was referred house
bill 1584 fn enact establishing a
capital improvement grant program for
the benefit of state fairs and
agricultural fears having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass is in a powered pearl for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with a majority report the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate
representative sherry dudsey for the
minority of the committee
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Music]
division has been requested members will
take their seats
the question before us
is the report of ought to pass on house
bill 1584 fn this is division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press a red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative boards
representative ford
representative egan
representative
hamblitz
representative kaczynski
representative knurk
representative love
representative
mcaleer representative o'hara
representative gail sanborn
representative schamberg
representative sumsitch
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to stay to the vote
236 voting yay 105 vote in a
committee report is adopted
and
it this is referred to ways and means
majority of the committee on expected
department's administration to which was
referred house bill 17 1417 fn local an
act relative to payment by the state of
a portion of the retirement system
contributions of political subdivision
employers having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator jennifer rhodes for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same
in being unable to agree with the
majority report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass senator
michael o'brien from the minority of the
committee
chair recognizes representative o'brien
thank you mr speaker
i arise in opposition of the uh
the committee report of the inexpedience
of legislate first let me give you a
little bit of background information
i was a firefighter for the city of
nashville for 35 years
i currently now serve as vice president
on this uh board of aldermen and the
city of nashua which gives me a fair
understanding
of what is actually happening here
when we look at this particular bill we
must remember when the state retirement
system started in 1967
a promise was made
to entice the other all communities
within the state
to join into from four separate
uh retirement plans into one
and that the state would pay 40 percent
in time that was negotiated down to 35
and for decades
it stayed at 35
but in very recent times
what has happened is
that 35 percent
was brought down to 30
to 25
in approximately 2011.
so now the state pays zero
now this liability that the cities and
towns that you live in
and if you have
one teacher
one police officer
or one firefighters you are making up
the difference
now whether you make it up
uh where does the money come from but
basically
debt is going
uh the state has paid nothing into the
retirement system on that so therefore
to me
this is a true
property tax bill the reason i rise
against the itl
is because
citizens need property
tax relief
by you changing
the committee's report of this
you will be bringing
some tax relief back to your community
not at 35
i'm easily 7.5
there's nothing in this bill that's
going to say as we march on to the
future and escalate but currently right
now
7.5 percent
it may be presented to you that this was
rolled back for the employees to make
that make up the difference
well when i started in the retirement
system we paid nine and three quarters
percent
it is now up to 11.88
your employees are tapped out that is
your employees in your community that
are tied into the new hampshire
retirement system
have
2.13 percent less spending ability
because of what the new hampshire return
retirement system has done
to meet that 11.8 day
this bill here
has nothing to do with the unfunded
liability
i support the unfunded liability
in order to make a pretty decent solid
pension system
again
this is just intending to be tax relief
to the cities and towns that are making
up to 35 percent deficit
now
where does that money come from it comes
from the property tax
money doesn't grow on trees
so i ask you
to override
the committee's report of itl so that i
can make
another motion that would be more
appropriate to assist
every
single
municipality
city of town and political subdivisions
that has one
employee
in the new hampshire retirement system
thank you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative mcguire
this is as the previous speaker
mentioned
not a question of the unfunded liability
except in so much as the only reason
the contributions to the retirement
system are so high is because we're
still paying off 20 years
of severe underfunding starting in the
early 90s
if we were only paying
the cost of the pensions earned at the
moment
nobody would
care but as it is the towns took
advantage of the
under funding for 20 for
almost 20 years
and at
for the last 10 years the state has
declined to pay toward their share
toward the
municipality's share of that debt
the one of the main reasons that the
state chose not to do so
is that every municipality
has full control over how many employees
they have and what they're paid
so that a town that has
six police officers like mine
pays
the same percentage as a town that a
similar size that has 10 police officers
we still pay the same
percentage but if we were to contribute
to the cost
of the municipalities that spend more
than others
we would be
charging the
businesses and people in this in the
more thrifty towns to pay for the towns
that pay more
i don't
that that's not fair
and i have to say that the reason that
the
towns are
didn't notice that the the employees
were paying
what had previously been the state
shares that when it was implemented
there were a large number of other
increases due to other unrelated changes
to the pension system
and so
they have
insisted that their
they just got cheated
and
that is not factual but
that's what they believe and they have
been trying for the last 10 years
11 act almost
to have the state take over part of
their responsibility
i think that we should continue to let
the
municipalities decide how many employees
and what they're paid
and include the cost of the retirement
system as part of the employee benefits
thank please vote green
mr speaker
for what members reason to remember rise
mr speaker i rise to uh request a roll
call
so brian has requested a roll call as
that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members take this seat
the motion before us
is the majority report of inexpensive
legislate on house bill 1417.
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
o'brien for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
their promises made in
that the state of new hampshire would be
paid
35 percent to the new hampshire
retirement system is a promise that was
made
and today it is a promise that should be
kept
mr speaker if i further know
that our people that live in our
communities
are burdened today with economic losses
and by the rollback from 35 percent to
zero payment
into the new hampshire retirement system
by the state
has put a tax burden on to our citizens
then mr speaker i ask you to vote with
me
and to vote red so a subsequent motion
can be made
thank you mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative tony
lakers for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker
if i know that cities towns and schools
determine how many employees they hire
and what they're paid and therefore to a
large extent determine pension costs
and if i know that given that if the
state were to pay a portion of the
pension costs the state should have
control of the number of employees and
their pay
and further if i know that when the
state stopped paying part of the pension
costs that cost was
shifted to employees not the city's
towns and schools and therefore had no
impact on property taxes
would i press the green button to
support the committee recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate thank you
the question is on the motion to
inexpending to legislate for house bill
1417.
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're approached you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative gallagher
representative levesque
representative perez
representative trelevan
representative ward
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
173 voting yay 172 voting nay
report is adopted
vote mr speaker
mr
speaker c3
for what members of reason remember rise
would a motion be in order
state your motion i move to reconsider
the vote on house bill 1417 and ask
members to vote no
the motion before us is to reconsider
the vote on 1417.
a division has been requested
members will take their seats
roll call has been requested
is this is sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members will take their seats
[Music]
members take your seats this is a roll
call vote
on the motion to reconsider
all right
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes
representative o'brien for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker if you know as i
know
that sometimes we do make a mistake it's
a little button
and that we may oppress the wrong one
so therefore mr speaker with that in
mind and also
if we truly believe in property
tax relief because that's the crux of
this
if you believe in that as i do mr
speaker then would you support
reconsideration of this bill thank you
mr speaker
the chair recognizes representatives
[Music]
chair recognizes representative maguire
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i believe we
have debated this bill thoroughly
and we are through with it would you
press the red button to confirm your
vote
the motion before us is the
reconsideration vote on
14 14 17.
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you will
press the red button
groaning stations are open for 30
seconds
so
[Music]
representative mann
not yet
great
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
180 voting yeah 171 voting no
reconsideration is adopted
okay
mr speaker
house will come to order mr speaker
what for what member does a member rise
what was november rise
uh mr speaker i moved to la house bill
1417 on the table
the motion before us is delayed house
bill 1417 on the on the table
[Music]
the division has been requested
a roll call has been re
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote on lane 1417 on the
table
[Music]
so
the motion before us is to lay house
bill 14 17 on the table members will be
in their seats
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
o'brien for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if you believe as i do
that property tax relief
puts things
on our constituents tables
not taken away from the table
so therefore if you believe in that
thought mr speaker would you vote for me
and vote read against the motion to
table thank you
the chair recognizes representative
mcguire for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that a change in the
retirement system contributions for
whatever reasons does not always flow
directly down to property taxes and if i
believe that the
municipalities should be responsible for
their own employees would i not vote to
table this build and press the green
button
the motion before us is to lay house
bill 1417 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're
approached we will press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
voting
representative cushman
representative perez
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
i also attended a state of the road
171 voting a 180 voting nay the motion
to lay on the table fails mr speaker
d1 mr speaker
yes
d1 oh i'm sorry
mr speaker i'd like to make a motion
and maybe you can help me with that
motion
what what is the motion
i'd like to make a motion to
refer this bill back to
the committee that it came from
that is a legitimate motion but to have
that motion pass it would take
two-thirds because it's an early bill
okay thank you i'll withdraw my motion
okay
mr speaker
what member what reason does the member
rise
question mr speaker this bill is going
to
is this bill going to finance
if it passes thank you
we're back to the motion of inexpedient
to legislate
i i
we're back to the motion of inexpedient
to legislate a division has been
requested
a roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded
[Music]
it's it's not sufficiently seconded
this will be a division vote
so
for that
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislative house bill 1417
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes
representative o'brien for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if you know i don't want to
continue to bore you with pis
but in particular just to rehash briefly
that this is a true property tax bill
that will help out our cities and towns
who have employees in the new hampshire
retirement system and if you believe
that every single taxpayer could use a
break at this particular time and if you
also believe that municipalities could
use this break
then would you vote with me
on the motion to
uh
vote against the motion of itl vote red
very confusing mr speaker thank
you chair recognizes representative
mcguire for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this is a bill that the
municipalities have been begging for for
the last 10 years
and that
we are not bound by the decisions of
previous legislators whether to share in
the cost of their employees or not
and if i know that their decisions on
hiring and pay are what determines how
much they pay toward the retirement
system would i not press the green
button thank you
the question before us is the eight
majority itl motion of itl on house bill
1417.
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
represent woodcock
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
road
171 voting yeah 179 voting may
the motion fails
mr speaker
i would like to be recognized for an
ought to pass motion
i recognize you to make a motion
mr speaker since the prevailing motion
field i would like to make the new
motion on house bill
1417 of ought to pass
the house will be in order
the motion
excuse me mr speaker may i have that by
roll call please
a roll call has been requested as that's
officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members take your seats
the motion before us
is ought to pass on house bill 1417.
this is going to be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes
representative o'brien for a
parliamentary inquiry
mr chair thank you mr speaker if you
know as i know
that this is
will gain
help to municipalities in the form of
tax relief
and if you know as i know that you can't
have the employees of the municipality
be solely the burden
therefore would you stand with me
and vote green on the ought to pass
motion and give true relief to our
citizens please vote green
chair recognizes representative allegro
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i knew
that what this
motion would do
uh
if
we adopt the idea
of supporting this retirement program
would spread the tax burden from some of
our fiscally irresponsible
municipalities
if if
if if i know
to if i if i know
that this would spread the burden from
some of our big big spending
municipalities
to smaller municipalities like campton
or thornton
or romney
would i then press
the red button
to vote this down thank you
the questions before us is the ought to
pass motion on house bill 1417. this is
a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
so
representative abbas
[Music]
awesome
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
182 voting yay 169 voting nay
mr speaker the motion the motion of
ought to pass the committee report is
adopted mr speaker mr speaker i rise
for reconsideration house bill 1417
and urge that people vote no the red
button
the motion before us is reconsideration
in house bill 1417
a division has been requested no mr
speaker i arise for a roll call
a roll call has been
is it sufficiently seconded
it is officially seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded it will
be a division vote
[Music]
mr speaker
over here at d2
where where are we right here sir
yes
i rise to make a motion to table the
reconsideration
we're in the vote we're in the voting
mode now
the motion before us is reconsideration
in house bill 1417 this is the division
vote
if you're unfair for your press the
green button if you're a pros you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
foreign
representative gay
representative desimone
representative judy representative
kaczynski
representative mackey
representative kittridge
representative pearl
representative nordgren
representative
wooper
also
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the vote
165 voting a 181 voting a motion to
reconsideration fails mr speaker d2
speaker
d2 i'd like to take him
can i finish first
this bill is referred to the committee
on finance
mr speaker d2
yes
i'd like to make a motion to recess
until tomorrow morning
i'm going right into the third reading
motion so
withdraw your motion please
the chair recognizes the member of the
child's motion chair recognizes the
member from charlestown representative
stephen smith for a third reading motion
thank you mr speaker
resolve that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be an order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
caption only and that all bills ordered
to third reading be read a third time by
this resolution and that all titles of
bills be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today
it'd be to meet thursday february 17th
at 9 30 a.m
we still have business to attend to so
would please everyone please stay in
your seats
we have announcements and we have
unanimous consent
question is on the third reading motion
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
representative reed has an announcement
members please
respect the
other members that are up here making an
announcement and making
a motion for unanimous consent
thank you thank you mr speaker and i'm
just waiting for some of my co-sponsors
to come up i would like the whole house
to be invited tomorrow all day long
we are going to have a chocolate
election you will be invited to sample a
wide array of chocolates right out here
and then fill out a ballot using ranked
choice voting to choose your favorite
chocolate
fun times for all and i really
appreciate everybody coming tomorrow and
thank you to my co-sponsors for standing
with me
we put before we get to unanimous
consent
if everybody will pay attention for a
couple of minutes i will lay out to you
how tomorrow morning is going to work
as you know we're going to have the
governor in for the state of the state
that is going to take place at roughly
10 o'clock
we are going to start at 9 30
we'll go through
uh the prayer and the salute to the flag
and then we'll go into
a brief
recess
while the executive council the supreme
court justice
the senate
the constitutional officers the
secretary of state and the treasurer are
brought in
and then the senate will be brought in
and then the governor will come in last
and do the state of the state
we're expected to last about 45 minutes
roughly what he is giving us an estimate
for
right after that we'll recess for 10 15
minutes
let everybody leave and then we'll get
back into the regular calendar which
should be between 11 and 11 30.
uh
representative umberger has requested
unanimous consent
for a memorial
thank you mr speaker
the honorable donald philbrick
passed away in january
he was 87 years old
don served for 14 years in the house
and 22 years as a selectman
in eaton new hampshire
his philosophy in life
was that you can't complain about
something
if you don't do something about it
this philosophy
is what led him
to initially run for the house
don served for 14 years on the
environment and agricultural committee
the honorable james finzee
james fincie a past chairman of
environment
and agricultural committee had this to
say about dawn
when i first got elected to the house
i had the pleasure to be seated next to
dawn
on the environment and agricultural
committee
he was a quiet
self-contained man
but quietly interesting
as had been the case through my tenure
in the house
that committee left politics at the door
and looked at issues and how they could
have a positive or negative effect on
the state's residents
since dawn and i were both from small
towns
we pretty much approached most issues
with the same point of view
don was a fine public servant
who did not succumb to partisanship
and i do not remember him being absent
more than one or two days in the time i
sat on that committee with him
when we disagreed on an issue
we'd argue a point
but never let that disagreement
interfere with being cordial
he enjoyed his work
and did a great job
we both took great delight
in the mammoth sludge wars between betty
hall
derek one
and dave babson
the honorable dave babson related an
interesting story about dawn
there was a discussion
or as dave called it a war
over biosolids and wood ash disposal
don asked the chairman
may i question mr hansen which has
nothing to do with the bill we are
discussing
but everything to do with mr hansen who
was testifying
the chairman agreed he could ask the
question
mr hansen
answered yes
oh sorry mister missed the the chairman
agreed
don asked
mr hansen
were you a pilot on air force one
bringing jfk back from dallas
mr hanson answered yes
don in his understated way
said i was your electronic officer
on that flight
needless to say
conversation on the bill stopped
yes
don also spent 22 years in the air force
and as an aside
you don't get to work on air force one
unless you are among the lead of the air
force don
thank you for your service
the honorable gene chandler summed up
dawn's service to the state
don was very thoughtful and did his
homework
his positions were well thought out
even if you didn't agree with him
he made a decision to support you or a
position on a bill
it was rock solid
and he would follow through
both at the state and county level
he was always concerned with how the
issue would affect the small towns in
the north country
don was very proud of his service on air
force one
as well as his service to his town of
eden
anyone aspiring to be a good or better
representative
wouldn't need to look much further
than emulating don
philbrook i firmly believe that each and
every one of us
should emulate dawn
be thoughtful in determining how you
will vote on a bill
do your homework
attend all committee meetings
sessions and county delegation meetings
don was an outstanding state
representative
and i have i am proud to have known him
may you rest in peace dawn
thank you
we all rise for a moment of silence
mr speaker
i would move that through remarks of our
friend from ksi be placed in the
permanent journal
without
without objection
chair recognizes representative branch
to unanimous consent
good evening uh mr speaker and good
evening honorable colleagues
yesterday marked 10 years since i was
diagnosed with stage 3 colon cancer
now i'm thankful for the fact that
cancer made me into the man i am today
and has made me appreciate every day of
my life
and to see the positives in every
situation
i distinctly remember that having cancer
and dealing with the american health
care system is what led me to political
activism
the hospital for which i received care
was charging my insurance forty dollars
for a single tylenol
that meant for a guy my size i need two
so that's eighty dollars for a single
dose
that means that during my seven day
hospitalization the hospital made over
one thousand five hundred dollars in
pure profit on tylenol alone
while the bottle of tylenol across the
street at cvs costed or costed it cost
6.99 at the time
dealing with cancer was already hard but
knowing that somebody was making money
off of my suffering was kicking me while
i was down
i will never forgive the system for
profiting off my suffering
and that of so many others and i will
continue fighting for what is right
today
mr speaker
a1 i
move that we
submit the former speaker's remarks for
the permanent journal
without objection
representative smith moves at the house
stand and resets for the purpose of the
introduction of bills and road billed
amendments and enrolled bill reports and
receiving the messages are ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those clothes may
the eyes have it the house is
the house is in recess until tomorrow
thursday at 9 30 a.m
and do not take your clicker with you
just so one more thing on the
governor's
state of the state
if you're not in your seat at 9 30
the chamber is going to be closed until
after the state of the state we're not
going to have people coming in and out
you